news this morning is a startling
incident in Washington D.C when fighter
jets caused a sonic boom That Shook
entire neighborhoods six F-16 Jets
scrambled to intercept a small plane
that had entered restricted air space
after making a strange U-turn Federal
investigators say the plane a Cessna
Business Jet eventually crashed in
Northern Virginia after flying over
Washington DC it appears there were no
survivors Jeff begaze is in Greenville
Virginia not far from this crash site
Jeff good morning seems like a very sad
story what are we learning
well good morning Tony this is where
that search was focused overnight you
can see behind me it's a fairly rural
area and so investigators and search
Crews really didn't have a lot of light
to work with as they were searching for
that plane we know this morning that
there were four people on board the
plane and fighter jets were scrambled
when the people on board did not respond
to air traffic control the cause of the
crash remains under investigation but
today military officials insist that
they did not shoot down that plane
[Music]
a sonic boom
startled the DC area on Sunday
it turned out to be F-16 fighter jets
headed to assess a possible threat over
the nation's capital
the FAA says that it was a Cessna model
560 like the one you see here it was
headed from a municipal airport in
Tennessee to Long Island MacArthur
Airport in New York when it reverse
course later flying through restricted
airspace over Washington
according to a NORAD statement the
military jets responded to intercept the
plane around 3 20 P.M
an even deployed flares to draw
attention but the pilot was unresponsive
by 3 30 p.m
Virginia State Police were headed toward
the scene it wasn't until nearly 8 PM
that search teams reached the crash site
on foot police said no survivors were
found this has the signatures of some
sort of incapacitation Robert somewalt
chair of the national Transportation
safety board from 2017 to 2021 one
possible cause of the crash the airplane
does not pressurize properly the pilots
become hypoxic meaning of course lack of
oxygen they fall asleep as do the
passengers because of lack of auction
they perish meanwhile the airplane
continues the plane was registered to a
florida-based company owned by John and
Barbara rumpel speaking to the New York
Times John Rumple said that his daughter
two-year-old granddaughter her nanny and
the pilot were aboard the plane and in a
post on a Facebook page appearing to
belong to Barbara Rumple she wrote my
family is gone my daughter and
granddaughter changing her profile
picture to one that seemed to include
both
the U.S Capitol was briefly placed on an
elevated posture when that plane
breached DC airspace it had been
cruising at about 34 000 feet before it
crashed this morning the search for
victims has been suspended it was
suspended overnight as well now experts
we talked to say incidents like these
are rare however they do happen once
every three or four years glad
such a horrible story Jeff sending love
and light to the survivors the family
members who have to go on without their
loved ones Jeff thank you very much